yeah so a little bit of background on
who we are
so we're from data made we're a small
web development shop here in Chicago and
we do a lot of work with primarily
mission driven organization so we work
with journalists we work with nonprofits
we work with governments and our work
ranges kind of from things like
developing web apps to developing data
visualizations to developing data tools
so we just have a lot of data projects
and through working on all of these
different data projects there are a
bunch of problems that we see over and
over again so we've developed a couple
of libraries to help us solve our
problems and we're going to talk about
them today uh so we're not here to talk
about data cleaning in the sense of like
stripping whitespace or like normalizing
data or like altering data in any way
we're here more to talk about working
with ambiguity like what to do when you
have data that's ambiguous and you're
not exactly sure what it refers to so
we're really talking about kind of like
inferring structure in our data um and
some background on ambiguity so
ambiguity arises when you have data
that's like entered by people people
make errors sometimes um it arises when
you have data involving free text cuz
language is complicated and flexible um
and it also happens when you have data
without unique identifiers which is a
lot of data in the world so as many of
you probably know ambiguous data is like
everywhere um and so why machine
learning so a lot of times when people
talk about machine learning it's frame
does this thing like this magical black
box where you like put in some data and
then like out you get like some awesome
insights and that's not really the type
of like stuff we do we don't really do
like glitzy things with machine learning
what we found is that machine learning
is like really well-suited to kind of
like
low level boring problems like data
cleaning um
so machine learning is a great approach
because it can work at scale like if you
have bazillions of rows you can use
machine learning clean your data and
also more sole reason is it can leave an
audit trail so if you're a reporter and
you're NER like trying to deduplicate
data or something you want to know like
all of the steps that a computer took
and then while earning you can use
machines to write some rules some
regular expressions but regular
expressions are painful and it's really
hard to anticipate anticipate like all
the ways that data can be messy so if
any of you like xkcd often I'm sure many
of you have tried like if you have
something worth like oh like this seems
like it would be really easy to like
parse addresses with regular expressions
I just want to like extract the street
name but know it can easily get really
hairy so the first tool I'm gonna go
over is Us address and this is basically
for helping you avoid writing regular
expressions for addresses so a really
common type of data that we work with as
addresses it turns out addresses are one
of like the most useful bits of
information for identifying like an
individual or an organization so we care
a lot about that so it's an open source
library you can get to it on github um
and what the library does is you give it
an address string and it'll break it up
into all the different parts like here
is your street number here's their
street name here's a city and we use a
model called conditional random fields
and the types of things that it pays
attention to like what it learns is it
learns the features of individual
components so the first thing you do is
you split your string into a bunch of
components a bunch of pieces
so it'll learn the features of
individual components so for example
it'll learn things like Oh
thing that is five digits five numbers
is often in a zip code but I'll learn
like Oh something that is has length 2
and is 2 characters is like off in a
state and it'll also learn things like
the relative order of components all
know like Oh like a street street number
is usually the first thing in an address
or like zip codes usually follow follow
states so how us address works is we put
together a bunch of training data that's
the stuff at the top where you have a
bunch of addresses where everything is
already labeled all the components are
labeled and then we feed that through
the model which pays attention to the
features and the order and then with
that um with that model that we generate
from our training data you can like feed
in a new address and then it'll it'll
parse it for you so this is a code
example for how to use it um you can pip
install it u.s. address you import it
and then you can have the address of
this venue here and then you can do us
address that tag we have two methods tag
and parse if you say have a spreadsheet
of addresses and you want to like split
it into a bunch of columns like one
column for street number one column for
street name things like that the tag
method is gonna be what you want so yeah
here you get a tuple where the first
thing is an ordered it and house all of
your address components and then they'll
also tell you what type of addresses it
is so this is a street address but this
library can also handle intersections if
you if you throw that at it and then we
also have the parse method and that just
takes each token and labels it each
token being like a chunk of the address
so here you can see like oh university
is recipient of is recipient 750 is
address number
um and the cool thing about using a
probabilistic approach is that we can
handle a lot of like weird crazy edge
cases cuz we just kind of like keep
adding training data when it fails that
stuff so yeah here are some examples of
addresses that it is actually able to
parse pretty well and I think a lot of
existing address parsers like anything
that relies on regular expressions which
fail on these so for example in Georgia
this Georgia address you have like 100
colonies square is actually the name of
the building and I think a lot of a lot
of parts would they can handle all
floors you can have like weird addresses
where you have like ranges and they're
also like weird roads in Texas we are
country road and then another library
that we developed for working with data
that's really similar to us address is
probable people and this is also for
parsing data like if you have a bunch of
names it'll like break it out into
chunks also open source and so it has
the same methods it has the tag the tag
and parse methods but one extra thing
that probable people has is you can
specify like oh I want to only use like
the name model or I only want to use a
company model so probable people by
default that can't handle both company
names and people names cuz it turns out
in a lot of real world data set those
things are mixed um
and yeah so probable people can handle
all of these weird cases where you have
couples so for example in campaign
finance data a lot of a lot of the time
the name is a couple it can handle
nicknames can handle names that are last
name first and it can also handle like
Dutch names and stuff and then if you
want to make your own parser we also
have a library for that so this is
called parser eater and this would be
good for any kind of domains that are
like generally structured but still have
like a decent amount of variation so for
example if you want to parse addresses
that are not us addresses like addresses
in another country another example is if
you want to parse like product codes or
something like that you can be like oh
12 pack of Twizzlers there's something
like that and say like Twizzlers is the
name of the thing 12-pack is quantity so
yeah if you want to make your own parser
parser ATAR will help you set up a new
library and what you'll have to do is
you'll just have to configure things
like the features that you want to pay
attention to and you have to configure
some settings it's pretty easy them you
could set up a parser and probably like
one two hours and after you after you do
all the configuration you'll just have
to create some creating data so parser
eater also has some tools to help you
label training data and then once you
get your training data together parser
aider has a trained command that will
just train on it and give you a model
and now I'm gonna all right Thank You
Cathy
so we actually created both of these
with libraries because we were working
on another problem which is the problem
of trying to find in a single data set
all of the records that
are about the same entity or across
different data sets which ones are which
ones are about the same person or
company or or organization and so this
is like this is actually kind of
certainly the same problem as geocoding
right where you have like a human in
term se string and you're trying to link
it up to a kind of canonical list of
addresses and so like this is the same
problem over and over and over again it
really it is the same problem so the
thing is is that a kind of good way to
start thinking about this problem is
that a lot we we have there's not a
slippage we were working with the data
that we think the the data is that
there's like the the thing that we care
about is not actually in a data although
we have our references to the things
that we care about like you know
campaign finance data we don't the
people are not there we reference this
event names are things are pointing to
them and those references are imperfect
and often times end up pointing nowhere
and so there's like this distinction
between Vidia that we want in the
reality that that we're hoping that it
points to is kind of really the kind of
heart of the difficulty of record
leakage at the duplication so you know
here's example of a single pack in
Georgia and all the different ways that
it exists and kind of campaign finance
data as the associated general
contractor's of America the Georgia
branch associated general contractor's
pack the Georgia branch associated
general contractor's pack Georgia branch
associated gin can't write like
sometimes address and I've not addressed
and like how do we these kind of big
pointers like doing the work of trying
to determine whether they're all
pointing to the same thing that's out in
the world
so the way that we do this is by
actually trying to solve a simpler
problem which is to try to find rows of
records that are similar to each other
but then that's that is actually a much
simpler problem because you don't have
to deal with these kind of ontological
difficulties but then you get to kind of
define what you mean by similarity then
if you so you want to maybe do things
like shrink distances or if you have
dates maybe comparing the the time
between different dates then you're like
well how do i integrate similarities
across multiple fields and then how do I
make this happen fast enough that I can
actually get a useful result so there's
a long line of research that is all kind
of part of what's called the Philly G's
Sun tripura dime that kind of goes back
to the 60s and dee doop is a open source
kind of realization of kind of the state
of art working that paradigm there are
other paradigms that are interesting and
some of them are kind of novel and
exciting but dee doop is kind of is a
isn't it's kind of the kind of
expression of kind of the longest line
of work of of trying to resolve this
problem so it starts with record
similarity so what we do is we basically
create features of distances between
rows and then we train a classifier to
combine those features to make it for to
give you a predictive score about
whether or not records are the same
thing or not and the way that we get the
labels is we use active learning because
one of the things that we've found kind
of over and over again is that what what
counts as an entity like really depends
upon the user that like that
how inclusive or how expansive that or
restrictive you want to be as as far as
clustering things together or breaking
things apart is not something that the
tool developer can really predict
beforehand and that really has to have
the end user in the loop for kind of
saying that no this is what I want to
count and bring together or not we kind
of surprising learning but something
that we've kind of learned unambiguously
so you basically we haven't this is an
interface to it so like where we use
kind of active learning techniques we
have a set of records that you've
already kind of totally dhoop about
we're taking a sample of those and then
we're gonna give them to the user to be
trained so so then we have a classifier
but the difficulty is if you did it
naively if you compared every pair of
records to each other that doesn't
that's scales basically do the square
the size of your data which is bad it
means that you really can't even when
I'm like modern hardware you really
you'd be limited the things that aren't
the kind of hundreds of thousands of
records and so you're trying so the next
thing to do to actually make this
problem tractable for larger data sets
is to find ways of only comparing
records that are likely to actually be
duplicates this is called blocking in
the literature and so lots of different
ways to do it and we actually we
actually do it in many many different
ways but kind of here you know you would
maybe make a rule that says on an
address field well I'm gonna compare
records that share the first five
characters and so we would end up
comparing the first two records to each
other there and the third and fourth
record to each other but we wouldn't
compare the first and third record or
the second and the fourth record or the
second three record or the person the
fourth record and so if you do this then
you can reduce the number of comparisons
I get to make by ninety like 99.99999
ways because it ends up that actually
like duplicates end up
getting really rare but the size of the
data that goes so that's kind of how I
mean like so those two things together
really the basic idea is you kind of
find a way of comparing records that
then you find a way to not have to
compare all of the records and then you
just kind of go from there
record linkage is kind of the same thing
except it's just two different data sets
as opposed to one data set we're trying
to find the duplicates in it so so that
so on a laptop like a fork or laptop
d-dip can handle around a million
records in a deduplication test which is
the hardest version of this test thick
record linkage is actually quite a bit
easier and in a few hours including
training and but you're spend more time
computing on the test data sets that we
have we're getting around ninety percent
precision and nine percent recall which
is doesn't sound terrific until you
actually compare it to what people do
which is worse
quite a bit worse so it's available as a
Python library we have repos called
YouTube examples that show you how to
use it as a Python library we have a
command-line tool called CSV d dupe that
lets you use it on a command line but we
built this for like oh this is gonna be
really really useful for so many people
and so many people didn't use it that we
were like well what's why aren't they
using our awesome technology and they're
like because it's really hard and you
have to be a Python programmer or you
have to be really comfortable in the
command line and that's for all
intensive purposes is no one so we have
built a service that kind of you were
you can get this functionality using
without having to to have those
capabilities probably people in this
room are comfortable using those tools
but maybe other people in your company
are not so this is available if you want
to take a look at that some of the
advantages of this is that you much
lower barrier to entry you it builds out
a workflow that for a kind of valid
that is important if you care about
really high precision and you can kind
of it's got some nice API to hook into
and some database integrations we can
talk more about that later few what so
yeah so it's in private Bayview and
check it out it's thousand rules free
you can come talk to us afterwards here
are some links to all the things that
we've we've shown you everything that
we've shown you here except for dd-do IO
is open source underneath the MIT
license so it's business friendly on
github dee doop that io it is the
service that's built on top of the dee
doop library but there's not any secret
sauce algorithmically that we're using
that we're not playing in the library
it's the same you get your good you'll
get a lot of you were not holding
anything back on that regard yeah so
that's that's that I think we can take
some questions at people the initial
part so yeah it really I mean we were
getting good we're gonna result really
early with addresses but then it got
popular and people are like well what
about this one so I mean that's I mean
that that's the beauty of it is is that
you're like okay great like tell me
about your bad addresses let's add them
in there and then it gets better without
having to like it's automatically but
I'm trying to figure out like okay how
do I change
how do I change how do I to add another
regular expression for this special case
yeah well so the so that's the recall
right so yeah so they I would say like
you know so that means that I'm sorry
the false positive
that's the precision right so let's see
so like so 90% of the records that we're
saying our matches are actually much as
that means 10% like are actually they
don't belong together so I mean like the
rate is gonna depend a little bit on the
proportion of the day the rate the rates
not actually great thing to look at just
because you think about it for a second
even if you have records that there are
a lot of things that actually match as
the data grows the number of possible
pairs grows way way faster so like like
for like you know so if you even have
you even if you've extremely you'd like
duplicate of data if you have data set
on the order of 10,000 and for all
intensive purposes like less much less
than 1% are actually of all possible
pairs are actually matches
you